[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
a prosecutor goes off for having to
dismiss dozens of cases
after appeals courts rule in favor of an
nfl owner caught in a sex stay
rich guys from a local country club
lined up to receive
sex acts also calls for transparency
after a grand jury
fails to agree on charges over the death
of brianna taylor
release the transcript release
the transcript we unravel the criticism
plus a defendant heads to trial monday
in the killings of his parents
why does he want the death penalty even
though the state wants him alive
and justice ruth bader ginsburg receives
a first-time honor for an american woman
law and crime daily covers courts from
coast to coast
[Music]
and welcome everybody to law on crime
daily i'm erin keller along with brian
buckmeyer and terry austin
former supreme court justice ruth bader
ginsburg lies in state at the united
states capital she's the first woman and
the first member
of the jewish faith to have ever
received the honor ginsburg died of
pancreatic cancer after serving on the
high court for 27 years
ginsburg joined narrow majorities to
uphold the constitutionality
of the affordable care act and to
legalize same-sex marriage
in all 50 states more fallout now from
the police killing of briana taylor
police have arrested 26-year-old lorenzo
johnson on charges he shot two police
officers during a protest related to
grand jury's decision
not to indict several other police
officers involved with the raid which
ended with taylor's death
johnson faces two counts of assaulting a
police officer and
14 counts of wanton endangerment of a
police officer
meanwhile the sole officer indicted in
connection with the raid on briana
taylor's apartment is out on bond
former detective brett hankinson posted
a 15 thousand dollar bond
and walked out of jail 32 minutes after
he walked in
hankinson is charged with wanton
endangerment for blindly shooting
into other apartments near brianna
taylor's his attorney says the evidence
does not support the charges
the charges hankinson faces are
indirectly related to taylor's death of
course
no officer has been charged directly
with killing her
grand jury proceedings are typically
secret but the transcripts
can sometimes be released an attorney
for brianna taylor's family wants to
know exactly what evidence prosecutors
presented to the grand jury
and is demanding transparency did he
tell them about the 12 neighbors
that sam aguiar's office interviewed and
recorded
that lived in close proximity of
brianna's apartment
that all said they did not hear the
police
knock and announce their presence
did he let the cops who shot
over 30 rounds of bullets in brianna's
apartment
one from outside the apartment shooting
recklessly and blindly
and the others who shot bullets into her
body
did he allow them to testify
before the grand jury did he talk about
them sending the ambulance away
before they executed this no not want
violating their own policies and
procedures knowing
that these no not warrants are dangerous
well if he didn't present these things
to the grand jury
what kind of sham grand jury proceeding
was this
it's not just attorneys but relatives
brianna taylor who are demanding more
information
terry austin has their reaction for us
terry
erin brianna taylor's family said
they're angry not only with the decision
but because they weren't informed of the
decision
before the public knew taylor's mother
was actually too upset to speak but her
sister spoke on her behalf
while wearing taylor's emt jacket
taylor's family released these
butterflies
in her honor they say they're
heartbroken
devastated outraged and confused
i never had faith in daniel cameron to
begin with amen
i knew he was too inexperienced to deal
with the job of this caliber
i knew he had already chosen to be on
the wrong side of the law
the moment he wanted to the grand jury
to make the decision
what i had hoped is that he knew he had
the power to
do the right thing that he had the power
to start the healing of this city
that he had the power to help men over
400 years of oppression
what he helped me realize is that it
will always be
us against them that we are never safe
when it comes to them
mattingly in the email called us animals
and thugs it's clear that that is the
way that they will always see us
and now to brian buckmeyer with
increasing frustration from the
community you see banding together there
for answers brian
erin it's a club no parent wants to be a
part of but they stand strong together
family members of the victims of police
brutality are coming together
to support brianna taylor's family jacob
blake who was shot seven times by a
police officer
in kenosha wisconsin his family says
he's unable to walk
but is hoping he'll be able to make a
full recovery his father traveled to
louisville to call for justice
we will not be moved that drive meant
nothing to me
hey because i knew i had to be here
i knew i had to be here standing next to
my
fraternity member we didn't choose this
fraternity
this fraternity chose us when it's your
child you can't
fathom the emotions that you go through
every night
you hear them talking to you
they're not there you hear them talking
to you
analysis now brian i'm an advocate for
transparency in cases like this too i
want to see the transcripts i want to
see exactly what legal arguments
the attorney general presented what
evidence was presented and try to get a
sense of why this decision came out this
way
exactly and i think everyone is in the
same boat and that i think for a case
like this should happen of course the
large majority of grand jury indictments
and cases are secretive
and there's a purpose for that but when
you look at what the aeg
said and how this case came out i think
there needs to be some oversight here
terry are you in agreement
i'm in full agreement i think when you
have something like this where
there are actually no charges against
brianna taylor all of these social
protests all of
these people are talking about the fact
you know say her name
and you come out with an indictment they
actually knew there was going to be a
problem they got the city ready
and they knew that they needed to make
an indictment as it related to her and
yet
they did not the transcripts might give
us some
answers as to exactly how this case was
presented and give us
perhaps some confidence or less
confidence in how it rolled out
let's go to an update now in the case of
the teen accused of traveling to
wisconsin and shooting protesters in
kenosha
kyle rittenhouse killed two people and
wounded a third during protests
surrounding the police shooting
of jacob blake his attorneys are now
fighting his extradition from his home
state of illinois to wisconsin
rittenhouse could face life in prison if
convicted on the most serious charges he
faces in wisconsin
written house's attorneys are
characterizing him as a patriot
who exercised his right to bear arms
during civil unrest and who protected
himself
when he faced danger others see
rittenhouse as a domestic terrorist who
incited the protesters
that's according to associated press
reports legal criticism is building up
against the attorney general's
interpretation of the law in the briana
taylor case we've been talking about and
we'll explain that
after the break and later on a florida
prosecutor goes off after being
basically forced to drop charges
against scores of defendants all because
of legal maneuvers
by new england patriots owner robert
kraft law and crime daily we'll be right
back
[Music]
that's not a criticism surrounding the
kentucky attorney general's announcement
that he believed the police were
justified
when shooting and killing brianna taylor
here's how the a.g laid out his
reasoning when announcing a grand jury's
refusal to
indict the officers involved
while there are six possible homicide
charges under kentucky law
these charges are not applicable to the
facts before us
because our investigation showed and the
grand jury agreed
that mattingly and cosgrove were
justified
in the return of deadly fire after
having been fired upon
by kenneth walker let me state that
again
according to kentucky law the use of
force by mattingly
and cosgrove was justified to protect
themselves
this justification bars us from pursuing
criminal charges
in ms brianna taylor's death an attorney
for brianna taylor's family is
questioning how kentucky's self-defense
law was applied to the two officers who
fired shots but who were not
indicted and i know that you don't have
the right to use the defense of
self-defense
when you injure or kill an innocent
third party
and what we know from sergeant
mattingly's own testimony to the public
integrity unit is that he saw
that brianna taylor was unarmed yes
his own testimony he saw brianna taylor
was unarmed and then you made a lot of
it you put a lot of attention on the
bullet that
the fatal the fatal shot to briana
taylor being made back miles cosgrove
if he wasn't able to see brianna taylor
to also see that she was unarmed
then he also was firing just as
recklessly as bret
hankinson and he deserves to be here
charged with won't murder
a brianna taylor if he didn't see her he
didn't have target acquisition
he deserves to be charged right now
so don't tell us that the grand jury
made this determination if it was truly
your determination
answer that question head on was it your
office's decision
or was it the grand jury's decision
release the transcript
a rutgers law school professor shared
similar sentiments on twitter saying the
kentucky attorney general botched the
law when the a.g said the officers who
shot at taylor acted in self-defense
under the kentucky penal code
self-defense is unavailable as a
justification and a prosecution for an
offense
involving wantonous or recklessness
towards innocent persons the professor
tweeted
even if two of the officers were
justified in defending themselves
against walker
taylor's boyfriend they may have
wantedly or recklessly injured or risked
injury to taylor if the a.g believes
that the officers did not
wantonly or recklessly injure or risk
injury to taylor
then he should explain why not his legal
rationale
is flat out incorrect brian buckmeyer
this is a lot of complicated legal
language so walk us through
the theory all right so the theory is
self-defense now the officer will have
self-defense as it applies to kenneth
walker but they would not have
self-defense as it applies to brianna
taylor because brianna taylor
is not the individual who use force
against them and they're responding to
there are other charges as well that
really brings us to the point like this
doesn't make sense
when you say self-defense you're saying
you committed the act but there's a
legal excuse
there's also assault in the first degree
which is a b felony for when you
wantonly exercise amount of force
and seriously injure that person if
you're not going to say they killed
brianna
taylor they definitely wantedly
disregarded her life and engaged in
contact that created a grave risk of
death to another
and killed her manslaughter you intend
to injure one person if i shoot at you
aaron because you shoot at me
and i hit a third person manslaughter
definitely says that's a crime
there's manslaughter assault so many
charges that he ignored
and the only way he could have done that
is by improperly charging the grand jury
so the bottom line here is if somebody
comes at me
and i defend myself that's one thing but
if i hit an innocent third party
the law of kentucky does not cover me
terry
that's exactly right under the kentucky
penal code there
is no self-defense argument if you are
an innocent third person and there's no
question that she was an innocent third
person
you heard nanita baker talking about the
fact
the officers saw she had no weapon
so she's innocent she's just as innocent
as the neighbors
and frankly the charge that they gave to
mattingly
that should have also been as it related
to brianna taylor as well and frankly
all
three of the officers good analysis
terry and brian
let's go now to dramatic video in ohio
of a defendant making a run for it
through a county courthouse
multiple security cameras captured
images of the men darting between
benches and around the bar where the
lawyers normally sit
at first it was two and eventually three
officers giving chase
the defendant emerged in a hallway
darted down a staircase
and got away when a rushing officer
slammed headfirst into a wall
and fell down the stairs authorities are
searching for 34-year-old nicholas kyle
garrison
in highland county ohio he was in court
to be sentenced in a methamphetamine
case the injured officer was taken to
the hospital for broken ribs
and a possible concussion this pineville
louisiana police officer who claimed he
was shot while on duty is now facing his
own legal trouble
his own department now says 25-year-old
john michael gallard jr actually shot
himself
and tried to claim he was attacked the
police chief considers the shooting
accidental but
since he says goulart lied about it
gallart is now
charged with one count of malfeasance in
office
a federal civil rights lawsuit is in the
works after a botched police sting
which caught robert kraft but violated
the constitutional rights of dozens of
people
we'll have more on that in a moment plus
a bizarre case involving a dismembered
mother and father
and a son who says he's innocent but who
wants to be put to death if he's
[Music]
convicted
a tennessee jury of 10 women and six men
four of them alternates
is set to hear a murder trial on monday
that we will carry live on the law and
crime network
32 year old joel guy jr is accused of
stabbing his father and mother to death
and then scattering their dismembered
body parts around the house
his mother's head was on the stove
his father's hands were on the bathroom
floor their torsos were soaking
in barrels full of acid the defendant
faces a possible life sentence with a
shot at parole after 51 years that's if
he's convicted
so brian opening statements are monday
the defendant is not seeking an insanity
defense
the defendant however wrote to the judge
asking for the death penalty if he's
convicted even though
he says he's innocent and even though
the state is not asking for the death
penalty
can you unravel what's going on with
this one
i wish i could this is bizarre beyond
belief and an identity to that note also
said
this note is not supposed to be an
admission of guilt uh in any way shape
or form
i think the the defense attorney's got
to kind of push forward and say hey
defendants say crazy things sometimes we
just can't follow them all
i've got to defend them zealously so
terry what might the defense be here i'm
going to ask you to step into brian's
shoes a little bit
is there a defense well the only defense
i think he really could assert because
the
crime was so bizarre is insanity but if
they're not doing that perhaps he was
pushed to the brink
perhaps he had some other mental illness
you know i definitely think because the
gruesomeness of the crime the fact that
he
cut up the bodies and put them in pots
and all over the house
they really need to come up with some
defense that's going to help him
serve time in a mental institution and
not in a jail
and terry prosecutors have some evidence
that the defendant made suspicious
purchases in louisiana where he used to
live but that's not coming into this
trial so that makes it harder for the
prosecution
absolutely i mean it's not coming into
the trial because the search warrant
wasn't specific enough
and that just goes to show you you
better be specific or you're going to
lose your evidence
exactly got to button up those search
warrants they have to be concrete they
have to be particular
well when we return we're going to hear
florida prosecutors digging in
on what he thinks was really behind
decisions by multiple judges in multiple
courts
to toss out evidence that the prosecutor
says shows an nfl owner was soliciting
prostitution
a florida prosecutor is sounding off for
being forced to drop cases against 25
defendants after losing an appeal
involving new england patriots owner
robert kraft kraft
forced changes or faced charges i should
say after a sting operation at a massage
parlor where authorities say
some patrons were paying for sex acts
the police installed secret surveillance
cameras inside private areas of the spa
but both a trial judge and appeals
judges ruled the sting operation
violated legitimate patrons rights to
privacy
an appeals court ruled video images of
each and every defendant must
be suppressed prosecutors say they
cannot move forward against craft or any
other suspect
without the video the risk of appealing
the fourth district court of appeals
three to zero ruling outweighs any
benefit
the attorney general was concerned and
we agreed
that the supreme court could expand the
appellate court's ruling to
ban hidden cameras entirely in cases of
prostitution and beyond
possibly impeding law enforcement from
secretly recording human trafficking
drug trafficking
theft rings chop shops and other
criminal enterprises
although i'm disappointed in the result
of these cases which arose
from criminal investigations in martin
county
the jupiter police department did the
right thing in pursuing the
investigation
and i stand behind the decision to file
the cases
the orchids of asia day spa was a
notorious brothel
in a family shopping center rich guys
from a local country club lined up to
receive sex acts throughout the day
until the place closed around midnight
31 so-called john and jane does alleged
through a federal class action lawsuit
that this very same prosecutor and the
police violated their rights to privacy
it's clear to us that at least 27
if not all 31 plaintiffs
are non-existent in our view
this federal lawsuit by what we consider
to be phantom plaintiffs
has been a tactic to pressure our office
to dispose
of the criminal cases the lawsuit has
demanded that we collect and turn over
thousands of pages of documents and
answer a ton of interrogatories
that would take hundreds of hours of
prosecutor
and staff time as part of
this civil lawsuit the lead plaintiff
and i were
court ordered into mandatory mediation
but when i showed up
the so-called lead plaintiff was nowhere
to be found
all this makes us believe that the
federal civil lawsuit is an abuse of the
court system
and i'm calling it out he's got strong
opinions there brian i'm sure you do too
yeah i i understand his frustration he's
used to
punching against criminal defendants who
don't have the power resources or
ability to punch back
and he finally met someone who does uh
the
higher courts agreed that they violated
their rights and i think they should
need to go back to the drawing board and
figure
out how to do these search warrants
properly because trafficking of any
people
is horrible and needs to be cut out but
not at expense of other people's rights
and that's what the court
decided and terry here one would think
that the attention could be focused
elsewhere
training education we had officers up on
the stand in the pre-trial hearing
saying that they didn't understand this
process of
minimizing their intrusion into the
legitimate privacy rights of people
well you would think at this point that
police officers would
know how to actually bring a search
warrant
and use the minimalization rule because
the penalty
is you lose all of the evidence so once
again we're seeing
that the fruits of this prosecution is
being thrown out of the window
we're not going to clamp down on this
particular sex
ring if in fact that's what it was or
we're not going to get craft because
if he was soliciting prostitution we're
not going to have that either all
because the police officers were not
properly trained and did not use the
minimalization method
so brian you said you understood the
frustration but my guess is that you
understand it to a degree
to a degree because i like everyone else
if this is a sex ring i want it closed
but i understand to agree because you
can't violate other people's rights to
do so
i appreciate the insight brian buckmeyer
terry austin and thanks so much for
joining us here on law and crime daily
where we discuss justice in america
monday through friday
[Music]
i'm dan abrams and this is the lawn
crime network
the only 24 7 network with expert legal
analysis
and gavel to gavel live trial coverage
watch the law on crime network
today
[Music]
you